PROFESSOR: I'm going to
write this e to the ikz
somewhat differently so that
you appreciate more what it is.
So e to the ikz, I'll write it
as square root of 4 pi over k.
You say, where does
that k come from?
We'll see in a second.
Sum over l, square root of
2l plus 1, i to the l, yl0,
1 over 2i.
Basically what I'm going
to do is I'm expanding
this jl function for large x.
So I'm going to
take this equation
and I'm going to expand it so
that the argument is large,
which means r is large.
I want to describe for
you those waves that
are really going on here.
So since the argument is
kr and you have a kr here,
that's the origin of the k
that I pulled out in here.
And then you have e to the i
kr minus l pi over 2 over r,
minus e to the minus i kr
minus l pi over 2 over r.
And this is valid for
r much bigger than a.
It's an approximate thing,
because we approximated
the Bessel function.
This is exact.
This equation is
exact for all r.
But that equation, now, is not.
That equation is
showing you that you
have here an outgoing wave
because is e to the i kr times
e to the minus i et,
the energy terms time.
So that's an outgoing wave.
This is an ongoing wave.
So this is ingoing
and this is outgoing.
So I'm going to say
a couple of things
about this that are going
to play some role later.
It's a series of comments.
Because this is a particular
expansion and due to the fact
that this is a
general expansion,
you could say that this
is an approximate solution
of the Schrodinger
equation far away.
But in fact, each
term, each value of l
is an approximate solution.
This is not an
approximate solution
because we added over
many ls and somehow they
helped to create an
approximate solution.
This is an approximate
solution because each l
is an approximate solution,
because to get a solution,
you could have said
l is equal to 50,
and that's all that
I'm going to use,
and that's an exact solution.
And therefore when
I look far away
it will look like
that with l equal 50,
and that would be an
approximate solution that can
be extended to a full solution.
So each l term here is
actually independent.
If you tell me a wave
looks like that far away, I
would say good,
yes, that's possible
and that comes from a solution.
You're getting an
approximate solution.
And you could make it exact
by turning the exponentials
into Bessel functions.
Even more, we will show--
we'll discuss it
a little later--
I could get a solution that
is approximate by considering
either this wave or that wave.
Suppose we just have
the outgoing wave.
The fact that the
Schrodinger equation
works for this one
approximately doesn't
require the ingoing wave.
The Schrodinger equation doesn't
mix, really, the ingoing waves
and the outgoing waves.
It keeps them separate.
So this is an
approximate solution
and this is an approximate
solution as well.
Every term here, independently,
every l and every ingoing
and every outgoing wave is
a good approximate solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
Now this is important to
emphasize because this
is called partial wave.
So the term partial wave,
waves, refers to the various l's
that work independently.
Now to motivate what
we're going to do,
I'm going to go back to
the case of one dimension
so that you need the
map to orient yourself
in the argument we're
going to do now.
So in order to
understand partial waves
and how they work, let's think
about the one-dimensional case
for a minute.
I used to do that in 804.
I don't know if that has been
done by other instructors,
but we've done in
804 that stuff.
So let me tell you about it
and how it works in that case.
So this is an aside
1D case of scattering.
So in scattering
in one dimension,
one usually puts a hard
wall at x equals 0.
There is some potential
up to x equals a,
and then there's nothing.
It's a finite range potential.
So even in the case of d equals
1, you look for a solution
when there is no potential.
This is the v of x.
This is the x-axis.
If v is equal to 0, you
would have a solution.
Phi of x would be a
solution, energy eigenstate,
and would be sine of kx.
This is the analog of our e
to the ikz, that we call it,
phi of r.
Here you have a phi of x,
which is the sine of kx,
and it's your energy eigenstate.
That's the solution
if v is equal to 0.
If v is equal to 0, the wave
must vanish at the hard wall,
at x equals 0.
So that's your solution.
On the other hand--
or, well, we can also write it
as 1 over 2i e to the ikx minus
e to the minus ikx.
And this wave is
the incoming wave,
and this is the outgoing wave.
Very analogous to
above, because this x
is defined to be positive
and plays the role of radius.
In this problem, incoming
means going down in x.
Incoming in spherical dimensions
means going down in r.
So we're doing something
very analogous.
That's why the study of
scattering in one dimension
is a good preparation for
the study of scattering
in three dimensions.
So you have an incoming
wave and an outgoing wave,
also because, again, there's an
e to the minus iet over h bar.
So here it is.
What we try to do is to
write a scattering solution
corresponding to
the same physics--
so the scattering solution, psi
of x, is the full solution--
is going to have the
same incoming wave
because that's the physics that
we're trying to understand.
We put the same incoming wave
and we try to see what happens.
That's what do we do
when we do scattering.
So if we want to compare
our solution to the case
when v is equal to 0, we
put the same incoming wave.
But then solving the
scattering problem
means finding the outgoing wave,
which now may be different.
Because, sadly, when
you have a potential,
you have something in, that you
have control what you send in,
but you have no
control what comes out.
That's solving the
scattering problem.
So the thing that
you have here must
be an outgoing wave, e to
the ikx, with the same energy
because energy is conserved.
We're talking about an
energy eigenstate anyway,
so it must have the
same energy, and it
must have the same probability
flux as the incoming wave.
So the magnitude of this wave
and the magnitude of this wave
must be the same.
It almost seems that you'd have
to write the same thing that I
wrote here, but no.
I can add one more
little factor.
It's conventionally
written as 2i delta of k.
A phase shift, delta of k,
an extra phase, and that's
the claim.
That's the whole thing.
You have to solve
what's going on here.
But outside-- and this is only
valid for x greater than a--
outside, where the
potential is zero,
you must have the
solution is of this form.
Here, this is for 0
potential everywhere.
So this was valid everywhere,
but in particular is also
valid for x greater
than a, and here we
compare these two things.
So this is the general
solution for scattering here.
And now we can also
add another definition.
We can say that
psi of x is going
to be equal to phi of x
plus the scattered wave.
Our intuition is
that this wave here
has the same incoming component
as the reference wave,
but nevertheless, it has the
different outgoing component
and that's the scattered wave.
It is exactly analogous
to what we did here,
in which we have the total
wave being a reference
incoming wave.
Well, actually, incoming
and outgoing wave.
The e to the ikz has
incoming and outgoing wave
and needs a solution when
the potential is equal to 0,
just like this one, this phi.
So psi is equal to 5
plus scattering wave.
Here it is the scattering wave.
It's purely outgoing, because
the incoming part is already
taken care of.
So completely analogous thing.
So let's solve for the
scattered wave here.
The scatter wave.
So in this equation,
we have 1 over 2i,
e to the ikx plus 2i delta
k, minus e to the minus ikx
is equal to 1 over 21, e to the
ikx minus e to the minus ikx
plus psi s of x.
Well, these two terms cancel.
It is the fact that they are
ingoing waves are the same.
And then I can
subtract this other two
to find psi s is
equal to 1 over 2i.
I can factor the e to the ikx.
That tells me it's
an outgoing wave.
And then I have e to
the 2i delta k minus 1.
That's a term there.
I think I got everything there.
It's written--
I'll write it here,
there's a little bit of space--
psi s as e to the ikx, e to
the i delta k, sine of delta k.
I factor out 1 times i
delta k, so this becomes
e to the i delta k minus e to
the minus i delta k, the form
together with a 2i in
front, a sign of delta k.
So this is your
outgoing scattered wave.
That's the shape of the
outgoing scattered wave
in terms of the phase shift.
OK, so now we have to redo
this in the slightly more
complicated case of three
dimensions and get it right.
So that is our task.
That's what we have to
figure out how to do.